allez on va ouvrir et bien la page de ce
club des territoires qui est consacré à
la disparition de Gérard Colomb qui est
décédé samedi à l'âge de 76 ans l'ancien
maire de Lyon ex-ministre de l'Intérieur
a été l'un des compagnons de la première
de la première heure d'Emmanuel Macron
et Mathias vous avez retracé le parcours
politique de celui qui a modernisé Lyon
modernisé la capitale des Gaules on va
regarder votre
portrait Gérard Colomb était un homme
politique à l'ancienne plus de 40
engagement au plus haut niveau mais une
grande partie passé à l'ombre des
projecteurs je crois que je suis comme
ça
donc ça plaît ça plaît pas en 1981 à 34
ans cint Gérard Colomb professeur de
lettrre classique adhérant du Parti
socialiste qui devient député du rô
c'est après Charles et jeanen une
nouvelle génération de militants
politiques de 30 40 ans qui accède
maintenant avec ses nouvellesces
fonction a une dimension politique
nationale et que pour la suite des
événements je pense que c'est
fondamental député puis sénateurs si ses
premiers mandats sont nationaux sa
véritable obsession qui le suivra tout
au long de son parcours c'est sa ville
Lyon candidat malheureux à qu reprises
de 1977 à 1995 c'est en 2001 que cet
infatigable arrache à la droite une
ville qu'elle détient depuis plus de 50
ans un petit peu d'émotion dans
minut je deviens maire de Lyon et puis
le désir de servir cette V à la tête de
la capitale des ga le nouveau maire
revais ses habits de bâtisseur avant
nous avions un immense parking à voiture
et donc personne ne pouvait venir se
promener à pied là nous avons
reconstruit sur 6 km un espace de nature
près du fleuve un travail de terrain qui
lui permettra de faire trois mandats de
M je disais au début de mon premier
mandat que nous avions l'ambition d'être
comme Barcelone comme Amsterdam comme
des grandes villes européennes tout le
monde riait et on s'aperçoit
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
passer devant un certain nombre de ces
grandes villes malgré la victoire de
François Hollande en 2012 sa stature de
sénateur maire de la 3e ville de France
ne lui servira pas de marche-pied
jusqu'à un quelconque ministère parisien
en 2014 il fait partie des
parlementaires de gauche dit réformistes
et prôent un socialisme du 21e siècle
pensez à faire en sorte que les gens ne
soient pas chômeurs penser qu'il n'est
pas des emplois précaires à mon avis
c'est ça le socialisme appliqué à la
réalité Gérard Colomb est un des
premiers marcheurs à croire en Emmanuel
Macron qui une fois élu à l'Élysée
récompense ce fidèle et fait de lui son
ministre de l'Intérieur et un ministre
d'État une expérience place Bovo en
demi-teinte et puis arrive l'affaire
benala ce que je peux vous assurer c'est
que tout ceci ne vient pas du ministère
de l'Intérieur la défense du ministre de
l'Intérieur déplaî au sommet de l'État
et marque le point de départ de
désaccord politique plus profond entre
le locataire de beauovau et le président
de la République avec une rupture
retentissante que aujourd'hui on vit
côte à côte et je le dis toujours moi je
crains que demain on vive face à face
une démission refusée dans un premier
temps mais maintenu par Gérard
Colomb de retour à Lyon l'idil est
terminé non retenu pour être candidat à
la mairie est battu à la métropole
Gérard Colom quitte la vie politique par
la petite porte dans un dernier mariage
de circonstances avec la droite
locale trop de gauche pour certains trop
de droite pour d'autres Gérard colon
n'aura suivi au long de sa vie qu'une
seule boussole celle de son bon sens
d'un tempo sans se précipiter et de son
engagement auprès des Lyonnais bjour à
tout le monde
voilà pour ce portrait de vous Mathias
portrait de Gérard Colom if qu'est-ce
que vous retiendrez du parcours
politique de jar colon bah c'est un
parcours un peu atypique parce que c'est
jamais quelqu'un qui a cherché la
lumière c'est jamais à l'heure de la
médiatisation à outrance c'est toujours
quelqu'un qui a été assez sobre de sur
ce frontl c'est un c'est une
personnalité qui n'a jamais renié ses
convictions c'est c'était un socialisme
extrêmement modéré assez je dirais e
d'une certaine façon
et il a il avait un attachement à sa
ville d'ailleurs il est pas né à Lyon
hein il est il est associé à Lyon mais
je crois qu'il est né à Chalon sursun ou
et c'est un type c'était un type pardon
c'est un homme extrêmement
sympathique un symbole de méritocratie
il faut le souligner aussi puisque ses
parents étaient des gens de d'extraction
extrêmement modeste et lui bah il a
réussi à à être agrégé de l'être
euh il était d'ailleurs extrême ement
cultivé parce que j'ai beaucoup parlé
avec lui de littérature je peux vous
dire que c'était toujours très
intéressant et puis bon il a cru aussi
c'est le premier he des premiersin qui a
cru en Emmanuel Macron puis alors après
ça s'est gâté parce que bah Macron n'a
pas tenu toute la promesse que voulait
mettre en lui le Gérard Colomb non c'est
un homme attachant on va évoquer très
attachant on va évoquer sa relation à
Emmanuel Macron mais Mathieu souer on
l'a entendu he dans le portrait de
Mathias à sa boussole première c'était L
en il s'est beaucoup investi pour
changer moderniser sa ville c'est ça il
fait partie de ces figures de grand-mère
comme on en a beaucoup connu il y a eu
bar d'ailleurs avant lui à à Lyon ou
absolument il y avait Morrois à lî il y
avait Jupé à Bordeaux alors la
différence avec ce que je viens de citer
c'est que précisément comme vous le
disiez dans votre dans votre reportage
lui n'a jamais occupé de fonction
politique nationale de de première
envergure si ce n'est à la fin grâce à
Emmanuel Macron mais il était y compris
au Parti socialiste plutôt en marge il
incarnaé d'ailleurs l'aile droite du
parti socialiste l' d des réformes
amateur avec une forme de de social
libéralisme assumé c'était ça
effectivement Gérard Colomb alors
peut-être du coup une figure locale qui
s'apparentait davantage à un George
frache c'està-dire quelqu'un qui pesait
très lourd et qui a fait énormément et
considéré comme tel par sa population
pour faire changer sa ville de dimension
mais qui au plan national en réalité
était relativement discret s'il a eu une
vraie politique une vraie carrière
nationale c'est grâce à Emmanuel Macron
et ça précisément en fait l'évolution de
la relation entre les deux dit quelque
chose de ce qui s'est passé au cours de
ces dernières années c'estàd que on a vu
que Gérard Colomb était un des premiers
à l'avoir soutenu peut-être même un des
rares il n'était pas très nombreux parmi
les politiques de premier plan à être
autour d'Emmanuel Macron en 2016 donc il
est vraiment celui qui lui a mis le pied
politiquement à l'étrier il y a deux
figures qui auront compté il y a il y a
Gérard colon au moment de l'impulsion
initiale et puis il il y a François
berou à la fin pour les 5 % restants les
derniers maîtres de la campagne mais on
voit bien que ce sont deux figures grâce
à Gérard colon d'ailleurs absolument
mais donc on voit bien que ce sont les
deux figures politiques d'importance qui
ont joué un rôle majeur en fait dans
l'élection de d'Emmanuel Macron il a été
probablement un des premiers et un des
plus fervants soutiens il a été ensuite
parmi ceux qui ont été le plus déçus et
et même les plus sévères dans le
diagnostique je termine là-dessus il est
celui qui avait dénoncé l'uriis
d'Emmanuel Macron c'estàdire que il y
avait la ligne politique mais autant que
la ligne politique il y avait surtout en
fait la pratique du pouvoir qui semblait
avoir introduit un coin assez fort entre
Emmanuel Macron et son son ancien mentor
oui voilà c'est une relation très
intéressante euh cette histoire entre
Gérard colon et Emmanuel Macron Gérard
colon il a d'abord senti qu'il y avait
une opportunité il a senti le vent
tourner notamment au Parti socialiste et
qu'il fallait plus se tourner vers le
centre gauche et une alliance avec le
centre droit Mathieu il a toujours été
marginalisé ou il s'est toujours tenu à
l'écarte du Parti socialiste et donc je
pense qu'il a trouver en en Emmanuel
Macron quelqu'un qui enfin correspondait
parfaitement à à ce ce qu'il pensait euh
à son adéquation adéquation idéologique
et et on le voit sur dans votre
reportage l'émotion qui l'étraint quand
euh bah il y a l'investiture du
Président de la République j'étais là
moi d'ailleurs dans ce et je peux vous
dire que ça ça ça ça a marqué toute la
salle quoi toute la salle des des fête
du du de l'Élysée c'est c'est c'est un
moment intense quoi il est au bord des
larmes Gérard Colomb pour lui et c'est
la sincérité aussi qui parle ça veut
dire que ça y est on y est ça y est ça
peut enfin marcher quoi ce ce ce
socialisme euh euh tel queil le
concevait lui et donc oui la relation
était très forte elle c'était la
relation d'un père avec un fils hein et
moi j'ai fait plusieurs émissions avec
Gérard Colomb pendant la campagne
électorale de 2017
euh et Gérard Colomb très vite dès 2016
il a il a accompagné il a il a et alors
là il est sorti de sa ville pour faire
des des émission de télé où on le voyait
jamais pour pour essayer de d'enfoncer
le clou et de persuader tout le monde
que c'était c'était le bon candidat et
puis Emmanuel Macron le nomme au
ministère de l'Intérieur et c'est un peu
ça devit être une récompense dans la fin
de carrière politique de jar colon en
fait ça devient une épreuve ça a été
compliqué ce passage à Bovo pour oui on
on voit que ça n'a pas matché alors je
ne sais pas s'il restera contrairement à
ce qu'a dit Gérald armanin ce matin je
ne sais pas s'il restera précisément
dans dans la mémoire de du ministère de
l'intérieur comme un des plus grands
ministres de l'Intérieur et on sait que
précisément avec l'affaire benala qu'il
a eu à gérer en tant que ministre de
l'Intérieur là encore le coin a été
introduit entre les deux un petit
complément peut-être sur sa figure de de
grand élu local un petit complémentté
deux petits bémol comme bien souvent en
fait ces figures de grand baron local
euh son sont sont des figures d'hommes
politiques relativement autocratiqu donc
on sait que précisément Gérard colon à
Lyon a a laissé assez peu de place pour
pour tout ce qui pouvait exister autour
de lui et y compris d'ailleurs assurer
sa succession et et et bien souvent la
fusion avec la ville précisément dure un
peu trop longtemps et on avait pu
observer aux dernières municipales que
probablement que Gérard Colomb avait
commis l'erreur comme beaucoup d'autres
avant lui en fait de prolonger un peu
trop l'histoire d'amour avec Lyon et
d'ailleurs c'est oui cette histoire avec
Lyon elle finit mal hein puisque et bien
les écologistes ont conquis la ville et
il a essayé tant bien que mal de faire
une alliance avec la droite alors qu'il
vient quand même du PS et voà ça n'a pas
marché oui non non il a et puis bon ses
successeurs potentiels ou ses héritiers
euh sont partis en guerre quoi c'était
euh parce que c'est c'est ça aussi c'est
il a divisé son camp enfin son camp ass
divisé euh c'est assez intéressant parce
que Lyon est une ville qui a souvent été
gouvernée par des grands élus locaux qui
étaient pas connus nationalement char
colon était pas connu avant que il
participe à l'aventure de de d'Emmanuel
Macron et avant lui quelqu'un qui n'a
rien à voir avec sa famille qui est un
homonyme qui s'appelle francisque colon
a été maire de Lyon vous avez eu Pradier
qui était pas du tout connu il y a eu
que deux maires nationalement connus
c'est Douard herot évidemment l'homme du
Cartel des gauches et puis Raymond bar
qui était le premier ministre qui avait
ét Michel Noir pour dem pour de mauais
raison malheureusement il trsj
malheureusement ou heureusement on sait
rien mais il est pas resté très longtemp
et puis Mathieu sou on l'a entendu dans
le portrait de Mathias au moment de
quitter le ministère de l'Intérieur
Gérard colonb a cette phrase je le
recite aujourd'hui nous vivons côte à
côte demain je crains que nous vivions
face- à faceace est-ce que d'une
certaine manière d'ailleurs cette phrase
a été repris dans les hommages qui
venaient de la droite ce weekend et du
rassemblement national est-ce que d'une
certaine manière il a été visionnaire
quand on voit l'état actuel du pays je
je sais pas il avait dit dans le même
temps en tout cas on a beaucoup retenu
ça effectivement les hommages qui
viennent de la droite point de ce
discours là qui fait écho précisément à
au discours de la droite alors ça fait
longtemps que une partie de la gauche
tient de toute façon un discours de
fermeté sur les sujets régaliens il
avait dans le même temps aussi fait
valoir l'idée d'un benchmark on va
parler loi immigration tout à l'heure
Gérard Gérard colon a porté lui-même une
loi immigration il a il y a relativement
peu de temps à à l'occasion de laquelle
il avait évoqué en fait le benchmark des
migrants et le fait que le système de
protection sociale français extrêmement
généreux produisait une forme d'appel
d'air bon il l'a dit ça et ça a été
retenu et en même temps pardon mais on
sait bien en tout cas les démographes et
les sociologues du sujet connaisseurs du
sujet disent bien que non précisément si
si Emmanuel Macron a su r rendre la
France attractive pour les capitaux du
monde entier Paris est redevenu une
place d'investissement ça n'est plus
depuis longtemps un pays attractif en
matière de migration et on sait que on
est parmi les pays européens en réalité
parmi les grands pays européens parmi
les moins attractifs donc l'idée de lier
en fait la générosité entre guillemets
de notre modèle soci
et une réalité migratoire soi-disant
envahissante en fait ne tient pas la
route de l'analyse en réité et trèard
dans les dernières derni dernières
années de sa vie finalement jar colon
est-ce qu'il s'est droitisé dans son
analyse de la
société peut-être oui cette phrase bon
elle a des accents de droite
effectivement mais je pense qu'il avait
pas besoin de ça il s'est pas droitisé
c'était quelqu'un qui était sincère
c'était quelqu'un qui était assez assez
direct dans dans l'expression et euh
après tout cette phrase elle a peut-être
une réalité et quand vous regardez un
peu la situation de la société française
parfois vous vous posez la question
quand même hein euh donc euh oui il a
c'était pas prophétique c'était euh un
sentiment c'était une sensation et euh
Gérard colon était sans doute ce parmi
le personnel politique il y a une chose
aussi vous savez il avait pris le parti
de segégolen royale quand elle avait été
candidate à l'élection présidentielle et
il avait cette chose en commun avec
Segen royale après on aime ou on aaime
pas c'est ce côté intuitif il était
intuitif et d'ailleurs il a été intuitif
en prenant l'option Macron hein puisque
ça a marché mais il sentait les choses
comme ça on va continuer ce club des
territoires en évoquant le projet de loi
immigration qui arrive à l'Assemblée
national il est débattu cette semaine
par la commission des lois et les
députés de la majorité présidentielle
ont déjà prévu de réécrire l'article de
la discorde anciennement article 3
désormais article 4 bis l'article sur la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension
député de la majorité présidentielle qui
veulent trouver un compromis entre la
version initiale de régularisation
automatique et la version modifiée par
le Sénat une version durcie avec une
régularisation au cas par cas selon le
pouvoir discrétionnaire du préfet on va
écouter et bien sur ce point le
président de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale Sacha aier qui
évoque et bien la réécriture de cette
mesure nous avons travaillé avec le
rapporteur général pour ten tenir compte
des remarques du Sénat qui nous disent
on veut pas régulariser tout le monde
parce qu'il y avait des personnes qui ne
le méritent pas don Tacte C d'ailleurs
l'idée du projet de loi initiale de dire
dans un article 13 tous ceux qui ne
respecte pas les valeurs de la
République on peut leur retirer ou
refuser de renouveler un titre donc ça
c'est conservé ce qu' ce que nous allons
écrire dans la loi ce que nous voulons
écrire dans la loi c'est que le préfet
délivre des titres à ceux qui sont dans
les métiers en tension qui justifient
d'une ancienneté sur le territoire et
qui par ailleurs ont une durée de
travail suffisante le tout dans une
expérimentation donc qui s'achèvera ce
n'est pas laappel d'air que j'ai entendu
dire ça ça n'est pas pour toute la vie
donc on régularise ceux qui sont là et
puis ceux qui par contre posent des
troubles à l'ordre public ceux qui sont
polygames ou ceux qui respectent pas les
valeurs la République le préfet pourra
dire non il pourra s'opposer il aura un
avis qui pourra motiver pour refuser
cette régularisation Mathieu souker à
force de réécrire cet article sur la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier est-ce que Géral daranin et la
majorité présidentielle vont réussir à à
trouver cette majorité et à convaincre à
la fois l'ile gauche de la majorité
présidentielle et républicain bah ce qui
se passe quand même dit bien que on on
est face à un sujet qui précisément
divise l'opinion mais qui aussi divise
la classe politique et qui surtout
divise la partie de la classe politique
qui aurait dû s'unir autour de cette
affaire ça divise la majorité parce que
ce que dit Sacha alier ça adresse autant
aux républicains que qu'à Gérald armanin
donc on voit bien que pour pour des
raisons de fond et on aurait pu aussi
évoquer la sortie de Gilles Le Gendre
d'hier ou de ou de ce matin l'ancien
président du du du groupe de la majorité
au au à l'Assemblée nationale on voit
bien que la la majorité présidentielle
la majorité gouvernementale elle-même
est divisée autour de cela pour des
raisons de fond il y a des divergence de
vue autour de cette affaire et et on
voit bien que chez LR la division existe
alors elle existe pour des raisons
davantage tactiques que de fond mais en
attendant on a chez les chez les
macronistes comme chez les républicains
en fait un sénat et une Assemblée
nationale qui par qui ne parle pas du
tout d'une même voix et on voit que on a
en plus chez les républicains
précisément au au sein même du groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale qui pourant n'est
pas très important de vraies
divergenence de vue et de vraie divergen
tactique donc cette cette idée de
cacophonie autour d'un sujet sur lequel
normalement la majorité gouvernement
gouvernemental pardon et la majorité des
républicains devrai s'unir fait des
ordres if trard est-ce que geréralin
selon vous va réussir à obtenir cette
majorité autour de son texte immigration
en fait il a tout fait pour dans la
coulisse pour essayer d'acheter entre
guillemets attention hein de de essayer
de de de rallier à l'abstention plus
exactement voilà le terme exact pour
rallier à l'abstention tion de quelques
quelques députés notamment LR justement
c'est ça c'est c'est tout le Paris
aujourd'hui c'est de de faire en sorte
que ceux qui sont michevre Michou qui
sont pas complètement convaincus mais
qui sont peut-être plutôt contre ce
projet de loi et bien ne vote pas et ou
s'abstienne plus exactement et donc
c'est c'est c'est le c'est tout ce qu'il
a fait et on a vu je crois que c'est
dans la tribune d'hier le journal de la
tribune di diche euh que euh il y avait
effectivement une 1putés 17 députés LR
qui ont dit qu' voteraiit ce texte
immigration s'il restait dans la version
dans l'esprit de la version du Sénat
dans la version du Sénat
euh exactement donc on verra ça moi à
mon avis c'est un exercice d'équilibre
extrêmement compliqué euh ça risque
d'être très chaud quand même pour lui il
y a trois options
soit ça passe pas euh et à ce moment-là
c'est un gros échec pour pour lui soit
il recourt au 493 cro avec la première
ministre alors qu'il ne veut pas
recourir ave enfin c'est ce qu'il dit et
à ce moment-là ça sera aussi un échec en
revanche si jamais il arrive à ses fins
alors là ça sera ça deviendra l'homme
très fort de la majorité il y a un enjeu
pour Gérald d'Anin il y a un enjeu aussi
pour les oppositions notamment à droite
avec ces républicains on entendait la
semaine dernière le président du groupe
LR à l'Assemblée nationale qui disait et
bien on ne va pas voter ce texte même la
version du Sénat finalement il y a 17 de
ces députés qui disent on va la voter il
a il y a un enjeu de Cré bité sur ce
thème de l'immigration pour les ouais il
y a une cacophonie totale alors même que
on a compris qu'on a compris pardon que
le durcissement que les sénateurs avait
porté durcissement de la loi que les
sénateurs avaient porté en réalité elle
fait plutôt l'unanimité désormais à
droite chez les républicains on voit
bien le la droitisation du parti il y a
quelques années les leaders de ce parti
c'était au moment de la la dernière
primaire par exemple c'était Nicolas
Sarkozi Alain Jupé Nathalie cocusco
Moriset et et encore Bruno le ma à
l'époque on voit que aujourd'hui les
leaders de ce par parti sont Éric cioti
Bruno rotaillot François Xavier béami au
Parlement européen et Laurent vquier
donc à travers y compris la figure de
ces leaders et les lignes politiques qui
les incarnent on mesure en fait ce
qu'est la droitisation de ce parti ou
plus exactement pendant très longtemps
on avait un désalignement entre les
leaders de ce parti plus modéré que la
base militante de ce parti qui sur les
questions régaliennes et en part en
particulier sur la question migratoire
avait déjà ripé en fait vers pour parti
l'extrême droite donc ce ce ce
précisément il y a normalement en fait
un alignement des ré publublain qui fait
qu' il devrait y avoir unité du camp
autour de la ligne politique retenue et
et et et qu'elle n'existe pas donc ce
c'est c'est ça précisément je pense
qu'il fait des ordres ensuite sur la
partie politique on voit bien que
précisément les voquier soioti retillo
et les autres ne veulent pas faire de
cadeau à Gérald daranin parce que
précisément parmi les héritiers de la
macronie à droite il y a éedouard
Philippe il y a BLM et il y a
potentiellement Gérald daranin faire un
cadeau aujourd'hui à Gérald daranin
c'est potentiellement l'installer comme
un héritier crédible de de d'Emmanuel
Macron pour 2027 et puis quand on va
encore plus à droite le rassemblement
national Marine Le Pen qui a dit que les
députés RN ne voteraient pas ce texte
immigration qualifier de petites lois
sur ce sujet de l'immigration on va
écouter le patron du parti Jordan
Bardella qui répondait ce matin
justement à sachaoulier sur cette
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier tous ces gens ont une
responsabilité dans l'explosion des
violence aujourd'hui dans les villes
dans les campagnes dans les territoires
ruraux et précisément ces gens-là qui
aujourd'hui ont une responsabilité
politique et morale dans ce que vivent
les Français viennent devant les caméras
de télévision en accusant et en portant
une colère beaucoup plus lourde à
l'encontre de ceux qui dénoncent le
laxisme l'insécurité et l'immigration
depuis 30 ans mouvement politique auquel
j'appartiens plutôt que contre ceux qui
commettent des crimes et des délices et
je trè quand on entend cette réaction de
Jordan Bardella on sent que le RN dans
le climat très tendu actuel du pays veut
encore créer davantage un lien entre
immigration et insécurité oui bah c'est
pas nouveau hein ça a toujours été le
cas c'est le cas je vous ferai remarquer
d'une grande partie de la du personnel
politique y compris à gauche maintenant
il y a plus tellement de tabou là-dessus
donc
oui mais cela dit c'est un retour je
dirais à leurs fondamentaux parce que on
les entendait pas très pas tellement
parler de de sujets régalien ces
derniers temps c'était plutôt d'achat
les sujets sur l'économie le pouvoir
d'achat la la la vie chè la inflation
c'était là-dessus qu'on qu'on les
entendait donc ils reviennent sur ce
sujet qui me paraît euh tout à fait dans
la droite ligne de leur discours
habituel hein Mathieu souer le RN essaie
de faire monter la tension autour de ce
texte alors qu'une majorité de Français
est plutôt favorable à ce texte oui
c'est leur fond de commerce alors
ensuite quand on écoute les propos de
Jordane Bardella en fait on peut
repenser à la façon dont Jean-Marie Le
Pen parlait déjà de ça il y a il y a une
trentaine d'années je dis ça parce que
dans les années 2000 Jean-Marie Le Pen
était leader de l'extrême droite
évidemment il il y ait alors sans sans
sans le moindre filtre à l'époque déjà
la question sécuritaire et la question
migratoire on avait au ministère de
l'Intérieur un ministre qui ne parlait
pas d'enuvagement comme le fait
aujourd'hui Gérald Darmanin mais qui
parlait de sauvageon c'était à l'époque
Jean-Pierre Chevenement donc on a le
sentiment que en fait 30 ans après les
discours sont à peu près les mêmes à peu
près les mêmes et on observe que en 40
ans on a quand même fait adopter une
trentaine de lois immigration je parlais
de la dernière avec Gérard Colom il y a
2 ans 2 ans et demi à peine en réalité
l'idée c'est quand même politiquement en
tout cas le signal envoyé c'est de dire
avec cette nouvelle loi on prend la
question de l'immigration à Brasc qu'on
réaffirme le fait que il n'y a pas
d'impuissance politique en la matière et
que au contraire le le volontarisme
politique peut obtenir des résultats
mais en fait non par contraste je dirais
et en creux à partir du moment où on a
aligné une trentaine de lois en 40 ans
en ayant les mêmes discours et et dans
l'opinion le même ressenti il s'agit de
ressenti mais dans l'opinion le même
ressenti on a le sentiment précisément
que l'impuissance politique elle est
pour parti là allez on va finir ce club
par notre revue de presse des
territoires
[Musique]
et Mathias à la une de nos quotidiens
régionaux on revient sur le drame de
crépool dans la Drome oui depuis le
meurtre de Thomas 16 ans dans la Drome
une campagne de représaille est mené par
l'ultra droite virtuellement d'abord
cette colère laisse aujourd'hui place à
ce qui s'apparente à des expéditions
punitives une tension prise au sérieux
comme le montrent les Dernières
Nouvelles d'Alsace et le dauphin est
libéré pour une situation inquiétante
que la police sur place juge inflammable
le Progrès de Lyon donne ce matin la
parole au lyonnais après les hommages
politiques le journal de Lyon donne
cette fois la parole à celles et ceux
qu'il connaissaient peut-être le mieux
ses concitoyens le progrès s'est donc
rendu dans le 9e arrondissement de la
capitale des Gaules fief de Gérard
Colomb pour recueillir témoignages et
souvenirs certains se rappellent d'un
maire visionnaire qui a changé leur
ville à la une ce lundi le retour des
Rumes également Mathias oui cette
inquiétude du journal Sud-Ouest les
gestes barrières se perdent porte du
masque dans les espaces clos lavage des
mains utilisation de gel hydroalcoolique
le journal de nouvelle Aquitane nous
rappelle l'intérêt de ces gestes surtout
avec un pic des maladies hivernales qui
pourraient arriver plutôt que prévu
cette année Alexandre donc on récapitule
si on a des symptômes grippaux masque on
se lave les mains et distance sociale
les gestes barrières et puis Mathia vous
avez vous avez décidé d'ouvrir une page
Noël on est quasiment à un mois Desf
voilà un peu moins de un peu moins d'un
mois déf c'est ça la voie du Nord a
réalisé un chariot test à moins d'un
mois des fêtes de fin d'année résultat
sans surprise les prix rest restont
élevé cette année encore sur un sur un
panier d'une quarantaine de produits
alimentaires du quotidien c'est
pratiquement 20 € de plus lors du
passage en caisse par rapport à la même
époque l'année dernière pour ce qui est
des stars des tables des fêtes le
champagne le foie gras et les hues les
prix resteront haut malgré une tenstion
moins importante sur le marché de
l'offre et puis pour terminer on finit
sur une note de conifè ouais c'est ça
estce que vous avez déjà fait votre
sapin Alexandre et ben oui ce weekend ou
c'est bon vous l'z bon ben c'était c'est
raté c'était peut-être l'occasion
d'essayer un sapin bio le journal du
centre nous parle dans son dossier du
jour de cette culture encore minoritaire
dans la filière du sapin de Noël du
Morvent pour les producteurs c'est une
charge de travail supplémentaire mais
l'idée avance dans les mentalités
surtout que pour l'heure il faut le
noter un sapin bio ne se vend pas plus
cher qu'un sapin conventionnel qui
plusit en passant par de la vente
directe merci beaucoup Mathias pour
votre revue de presse régionale on finit
par la unee du Figaro Yve avec ce ce
titre l'économie ralenti Macron cherche
un nouveau souffle oui parce que c'était
le le le front sur lequel bah il avait
les meilleurs succès notamment l'emploi
et puis là on voit que le chômage repart
à la hausse et puis les nuages
s'accumulent à l'horizon et donc il y a
une des perspectives économiques qui
sont beaucoup moins favorables que ne
l'était jusqu'à présent quand le reste
marche pas très fort
bah ça va être un passage difficile ça
va être compliqué merci beaucoup à tous
les quat à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce club des territoires
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez-vous à 18h
avec votre émission s public présenté
par Thas HUG et puis demain vous
retrouverez à cette place Orian manchini
très bonne journée sur public
sc